silently they hold up photographs
mothers fathers siblings and lovers all
that disappeared
their uyghurs flung into chinese camps
their relatives say it's ethnic
cleansing
the chinese say that's baseless and they
vigorously denied any mistreatment
they want to terminate all about the
vegas
so this is a crime against the humanity
crime against the regular people gulbaha
is one of the few survivors she feels
she's come back from the dead
she was thrown into an underground
prison just like this she says
crowded with 40 others in chains for 17
hours a day
i was held in what they called the tiger
chair she tells us
like this my arms bolted down my legs
chained
interrogated for 24 hours before
fainting
the others listened horrified as she
said she was injected regularly with
unknown drugs
she showed me a video taken of her soon
after she was freed after more than a
year in the camp
she's covered in hives and an angry red
rash
other weakers with missing relatives are
desperate
my mother their family our family member
no in the hell not in the prison
they are not prison like a uh another
country like a
british prison not like turkish that is
a hill
that is a hill turkey is now home to the
biggest weaker diaspora outside china
fifty thousand uyga muslims are in exile
most of them in istanbul
having fled a crackdown in the chinese
territory of xinjiang
here they sit in cafes enjoying wiga
food
and can browse shops selling weaker
clothes and books all
banned in their homeland but every one
of them has a tale of persecution
against the relatives they've left
behind
the osmond family set up a barber's shop
hatichi shows us their passports the
chinese government gave us these she
says
now they're calling us terrorists her
parents brother and brother-in-law were
jailed
she hasn't heard from them for four
years
in istanbul to keep their language alive
but even the turkish leadership is now
being criticized for not doing enough to
defend the uyghurs
because of china's growing economic
clout here
[Music]
the weeders are feeling more and more
alone
alex crawford sky news in istanbul